magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman the last
24 hours have been some of the craziest
and most disturbing in many ways in the
sort of news cycle that we've seen in
weeks and we're going to talk about the
sean hannity text messages we're going
to talk about the trump riot anniversary
and donald trump cancelling his press
conference scheduled for tomorrow but
before we do any of that
i have what is one of the
wildest interviews that i have seen
certainly in months it is an interview
that took place on msnbc host ari melber
interviewed peter navarro peter navarro
was donald trump's assistant he was
assistant to the president for a period
of time he was trump's director of trade
and manufacturing policy he was the
national defense production act policy
coordinator
and he is freely admitting
that he was one of the planners
of the attempted coup to steal an
election that donald trump didn't win i
don't think we need really more
introduction i'm just gonna get right
into the material
peter navarro admits to the entire thing
here and it is
let's just get into the clips because
there's just so much this first clip is
kind of the back story
why did peter navarro start developing
with trump this plan for a coup well it
was all based on false beliefs slash
lies slash
misunderstandings slash distortions
let's start right there
sure the back story is while i was in
the administration after the election
beginning on thanksgiving
i produced what would be an exhaustive
three volume report i went over tens of
thousands of pages of documents and
proved
that the election was on all likelihood
stolen through fraud and election
irregularities that's the back
background on january 6th that's the
green bay plan that's false but i the
question for the start of the interview
will be yes it is but that's the
question for the start of the interview
navarro says we'll disagree about
whether the election really was or
wasn't stolen
you have to put aside the disagreement
to proceed and ari melber ultimately
does it
but
everything is predicated on that and so
it's sort of the crucial point that that
entire premise was untrue let's continue
i just want to i just want to make sure
here that we're kind of going by rules
of the road the question is yeah i know
and you'll get time to talk you've got
to say that and and what i'm saying is
that i don't have to say anything sir
i'm asking you the question is
what was the plan itself and who was in
on it right exactly and i'm going to
tell you that the plan was simply this
we had over a hundred congressmen and
senators on capitol hill ready to
implement the sweep the sweep was simply
that we were going to challenge
the the results of the election in the
six battleground states they were
michigan pennsylvania uh
georgia wisconsin uh nevada and and
basically these were the places where we
believed that if the votes were sent
back to those battleground states
and looked at again that there would be
enough concern amongst the legislatures
that
most or all of those states would
decertify the election now of course
that wasn't true it didn't happen there
was no such evidence but this is the
same plan that was written up in the
memo by trump's lawyer so it's all
coherent there it's there's no doubt as
to whether that was the plan it was that
would throw the election to the house of
representatives and i would say to you
here ari that all of this again i was it
was in
in the lanes legally it was prescribed
by the constitution there is a provision
to go rather than through the electoral
college to the house of representatives
and all this required
was peace and calm on capitol hill and
at 1 p.m
ted cruz senator ted cruz and gosart a
representative started the green bay
sweep beautifully so the ar the premise
here is
had it not been for the riots had it not
been for the riots
they would have had a shot at carrying
this plan forward which is a new way
that they are sort of denouncing the
some of them are pretending there were
no riots some of them are arguing that
the riots were peaceful in one sense the
riots were part of the plan as far as
trump was concerned but some of these
people who had what they thought was a
more clever way to steal the election
are saying actually the violence got in
the way because it interrupted what we
were going to do have pence reject
electors etc now we get to just an
incredible part where ari melber
straight up says to navarro
you're describing a coup do you realize
that take a look at this incredible
video rather than through the electoral
college to the house of representatives
and all this required
was peace and calm on capitol hill and
at 1 p.m
ted cruz senator ted cruz and gosar a
representative started the green bay
sweep beautifully challenging the
results of arizona here's the most
important thing i can tell you about
this
the the thing that we were trying to
deal with was was a media which refused
to acknowledge any kind of possible
fraud or irregularities right let's get
into it i've given you peter i've given
you i've given you some time here and i
think you you've you've explained that
i'm going to follow up here and i want
us to have a back and forth but that
involves both of us you just described a
way yeah you just described
this plan
as a way to take an election where the
outcome was established by independent
secretaries of state by the voters of
those states and legal remedies have
been exhausted with the supreme court
never even taking let alone siding with
any of the claims that you just referred
to so legally they went nowhere and then
you're describing a way that the
incumbent hold on hold on you will get
your turn i just let you go for a while
let's go this back and forth sir
then
you will use the incumbent
losing party's power that was the
republican party that was losing power
to overtake and reverse that outcome
do you realize you are describing a coup
no i i totally reject many of your
premises there first of all the election
was still in doubt and would be until it
was certified second the idea now that
it that isn't you cannot ever satisfy
that
because he is saying the election is in
doubt until it's certified
but his plan was to prevent its
certification based on alleged doubts
that he is raising that can never be
satisfied you can never satisfy that and
ari melbourne is is pointing out the
crucial part
all of these independent thing
individual secretaries have stayed in
different states many republicans said
there isn't evidence for this so you
check that off the list
courts throughout i think it was 63
different complaints that were made
maybe one was sort of
provisionally accepted on theoretical
grounds but
courts did not find that their claims
were with merit the supreme court
declined to take it up so at a certain
point you can't say
we are acting on the basis of
x that justifies it because every legal
and sensible empirical remedy had been
exhausted and had been rejected and then
he says well until it's certified then
it is in doubt but you're the one
preventing its certification it's a
circle
that secretaries of state particularly
in michigan and and and pennsylvania
were like innocent parties i mean
jocelyn benson and kathy bookfar the
secretary of state in michigan and
pennsylvania they were put in power by
george soros
for the express purpose of shifting the
playing field wow
wow
so then lastly here
why wasn't navarro more involved in
pushing mike pence to do the thing they
wanted him to do remember trump wanted
pence to reject this and to stop that
and to seat a different slate of
electors and navarro seems to say he was
basically kept away from mike pence
conversation why wouldn't he listen to
you do you think why wouldn't he listen
to you
well i talk about in the in trump time
book his chief of staff mark short who
is a coke network conservative meaning
that he's a never trumper basically
walled off vice president pence from the
day mark took us took chief of staff's
duties back in 2018 and it was a sad
story mike was always good to me until
that day the thing about mike's betrayal
of president trump which is really
interesting is he never shared the legal
analysis of his general counsel greg
jaffe right and mark short with pat but
again that really peter that brings us
back
but that brings us back to the same
point
and this may be this may be relevant sir
in future elections which is
don't you think somebody would have
thought of this if the incumbent
administration through the president or
the vice president could just cancel the
election outcome because he goes down to
the senate well then a lot of people
would try to stay in power we have an
entire system designed to thwart and i
want to say this respectfully but it's
the truth people like you to stop people
like you who think that you can anoint
yourself the reviewers of the voters of
the american people of what they
lawfully did that you trump the supreme
court no pun intended people like you
are what the constitution are designed
to stop and it worked and it did stop
you which i guess brings us to
you know incredible i mean truly
incredible he's admitting to the entire
thing and it was all based on their
opinion
which was rejected
or not corroborated by every secretary
of state that was pulled into it by
every court that was pulled into it and
ultimately the supreme court saying
there's not even anything here for us
opting not to take this up despite
having uh three justices on it selected
by donald trump
this is exhibit a evidence admitting to
the entire thing pulling together every
aspect of it every aspect of it it's
incredible all right let's now move on
to
the one year anniversary of the january
six trump riots uh a year minus a day
ago being january 5th this was january
6th of last year
many of us about one and a quarter
million of you
tuned in to pieces of my coverage of the
trump riots it feels like it was
yesterday it's now been a year in that
year we have seen hundreds of cases
against the rioters move forward who
were clearly trump supporters we have
learned more about
yes the plan the plan the expectation
the hope from trump and trumpists that
this or anything would prevent the
certification of joe biden's win
um on january 6th
and uh donnie o'sullivan or dhoni i
forget exactly how it's pronounced it's
or donairdani from cnn he's excellent
he went and interviewed trumpists one
year on from the trump riots have they
come around to reality in any way on
what took place
have they accepted that it was trump
people who did the rioting and joe biden
did win the election
they have not this is one of the most
stunning p if there were a sociological
time capsule to look at a thousand years
from now
this video should be on it let's jump
right into it january 6 attack was not
the republicans nor trump it was the
democrats were behind it all
they're the ones that caused it all do
you really believe that
i know it and there is no way
that a republican
would act that way and there is no way
that trump had anything to do
with what happened on january 6. this is
the no true scotsman fallacy this is by
definition the rioters couldn't have
been trumpists because no republicans
would ever do that
it's a closed loop it's doxastic closure
it is an indefeasible statement call it
whatever you want
you cannot reason
people out of that belief because there
is no reason as to why they hold it
you just can't do it by definition the
rioters weren't republicans because
republicans wouldn't riot wow
strong statement but what about all the
trump supporters that have been charged
and indicted
because it's all democratic
judges and
people that were on the take from the
democrats
it's been a year since the attack on the
u.s capitol
and because of disinformation denial and
diversion americans don't have a shared
history a shared understanding of what
happened here on that day also i think
the whole reporting of it is a giant
hoax
we are very peaceful people so it was a
total setup to me it was the fbi had set
it up i don't believe that they were
trump supporters that did that right you
said the whole thing's a setup you don't
really believe that do you i do
i do
because trump won the election
they they
they've proven it over and over again i
really don't think trump had much to do
other than people that were supporters
for him
some were involved but i think they were
enticed by
the fbi this is why i say we have to
take very seriously the possibility of
something even worse in 2024
listen to what these people are saying
there's no there's no entry point
to disabuse these folks of these false
beliefs and by by
you know undercover agents
dear god when i spoke to trump
supporters here in washington on january
6 most were in denial about the results
of the 2020 election do you accept that
biden won the election
absolutely not
biden did not win this election
on january 6 we walked with trump
supporters who marched from the white
house where trump was doing a speech
here to the u.s capitol and as we
arrived here that is when the first
security barrier was breached
[Applause]
at the time some trump supporters told
me they were happy with what happened
here at the capitol are you proud of
what happened here today absolutely
i think we should have gone on in and
yanked
the our senators out by the hair of the
head and drug them out and said no more
now understand that
now they say no republican would ever
behave that way anyone who did that
stuff wouldn't be a republican
and yet a year ago here are republicans
saying we should go in there and drag
senators out by their hair so are are
these the people that are the fake
republicans i'm absolutely uh stand
behind 100 percent what happened here
today
one thousand percent it's terrible how
this election was stolen
federal prosecutors have charged more
than 700 people in connection with the
capital rise and repeatedly documented
the writer's support for president trump
but some people in right-wing media have
pushed the dangerous idea that it was
all an fbi plot fbi operatives were
organizing the attack on the capitol
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that this was some kind of
false flag event staged by the democrats
or the fbi
what would you say to people who say
january 6th was the biggest attack on
american democracy
but amid all the denial and deflection i
met one trump supporter who said it was
important to be real about what happened
on that day what do you think of the
trump supporters that stormed the
capitol
oh my
you talk about mis
misfound feelings um
seeing the folks from my side of the
state that were there
and they're not the part of the campaign
that we would like to have do you think
some trump supporters that say it's
antifa it's black lives matter that they
know that that's [ __ ] but they just
don't want to admit it's easier to blame
someone else
everyone is afraid to
you know
take the blame
so that last point is an important one
and we've talked about it before
do these trumpists literally believe
that trump won
and that the rioters were antifa and the
fbi or
is it something they say to signal that
they're on the team
and they accept that sometimes in a war
you've got to tell lies or whatever
because of the greater good we don't
really have the answer to the question
the answer is probably some of them
really do believe it but some of them
understand that in order to show that
i'm on the team
it's what i've got to say one year later
and it is as bad as it has ever been
which should really scare us about 2024.
let's take a quick break you can find me
on twitter at dpakman and let me know uh
your thoughts about these incredible
videos one of our sponsors is magic
spoon breakfast cereal sweet and tasty
like the cereals i loved as a kid but
without the sugar or the carbs every
serving of magic spoon has zero grams of
sugar only four net carbs 140 calories
and packed with 13 grams of protein
perfect if you're doing keto perfect if
you're doing low carb great if you're
just trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout
remember that you can sign up and get a
membership to the david pakman show at
joinpackman.com not only our memberships
our primary source of funding very very
important as we are now in an election
year you also get a bunch of great perks
including an extra show every day that
we do called the bonus show commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
priority access to viewer town halls and
so many other great things sign up at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code
wow22 wow 22. it's an impressive
discount code okay the trump riot
committee
wants to talk to fox news propagandist
sean hannity and why wouldn't they i
mean at the end of the day this is not a
big shock sean hannity became
i don't know if we can say friend trump
doesn't really seem to have friends in
the way you or i might use the term but
he became a colleague or associate of
donald trump's regularly talking to
donald trump and clearly was involved as
the riots and the attempts to steal the
election were going on
the house committee investigating the
riots now wants to talk to sean hannity
and they've released some text messages
that are stunning not in that
hannity is suggesting crazy things
but in that it makes clear that hannity
knew what was being done was a bad idea
but then he went on to tell lie after
lie after lie about the 2020 election on
his show and about the january 6th 2021
riots on the program axios reporting
january 6th committee requests sean
hannity's cooperation
they have requested fox news channel
host sean hannity voluntarily
voluntarily cooperate with the
investigation hannity is one of the most
prominent media figures in america was a
close adviser to trump throughout his
presidency
the committee revealed last month that
hannity texted then-white house chief of
staff mark meadows during the riot to
urge him to get trump to stop his
supporters
hannity condemned the attack on the
capital saying on his show on the night
after the riot that all of today's
perpetrators must be arrested or
prosecuted but hannity has never
criticized trump for his role in ginning
up the crowd in dc that day and he has
criticized the congressional committee
investigating january 6th article from
the daily beast
revealed sean hannity's other desperate
texts about january 6th i'm very worried
about the next 48 hours he texted mark
meadows hours before a magamob's violent
attack on the capital
we can't lose the entire white house
council's office hannity wrote to
meadows on december 31st 2020.
i do not see january 6th happening the
way he is being told
after the sixth he should announce will
lead the nationwide effort to reform
voting integrity go to florida watch joe
mess up daily stay engaged when he
speaks people will listen it's not
terrible advice from sean hannity
it's not what trump ultimately did but
the committee wrote to hannity that that
message quote suggests that you had
knowledge of concerns by trump's white
house counsel's office regarding the
legality of the former president's plan
for january 6th
january 5 2021 i'm very worried about
the next 48 hours the committee further
asks hannity why were you concerned
about the next 48 hours
um
incredible incredible
that the public facing stuff hannity was
doing
reflected 180 degree different
perspective on what did and was taking
place than what hannity was texting
behind the scenes same could apply to
laura ingram as we've talked about
before
here is adam schiff appearing on msnbc
yesterday asked
you're looking for info and cooperation
from hannity and adam schiff says yes we
are
are you looking for information or for
cooperation from mr hannity
yes and i think you'll see an
announcement about that uh very soon um
you know we believe that he was texting
with the chief of staff
and that he has information that would
be relevant to our committee
he was more than a fox
host he was also a
confident adviser campaigner for the
former president
and i would hope that he's asked by the
committee as i suspect he will be very
soon that he would cooperate with us
unclear if that will actually happen
congresswoman lofgren was also asked
about zoe lofgren asked about why
hannity and she says well we have dozens
of texts from hannity take a look at
this activity he is a fact witness we uh
have in our possession dozens of texts
that he sent to
mark meadows and others in his role as a
parent political operative
um indications of his communications
with the president and others on
strategy and it's that that we would
like to talk to him about i want to make
sure that everyone knows this isn't a
subpoena we've asked him uh to cooperate
with us as a fact witness uh out of his
sense of patriotism yeah well good luck
with that so we'll see if hannity does
show up um another very interesting text
that was uh published by cnn's brian
stelter highlighted by brian stelter
relatively early on quote guys we have a
clear path to land the plane in nine
days this was nine days before
biden was sworn in he can't mention the
election ever again
ever
and clearly hannity saw even if not out
of a moral duty to say trump's got to
stop this stuff out of a strategic duty
to the republican party hannity saying
he's got to stop with the election we
can land the plane he can go to florida
criticize biden
but stop talking about the election
obviously that's not ultimately what
happened and this all makes hannity's
promotion
of lies conspiracy theories and the like
even more vile even more dishonest even
more immoral i don't expect hannity to
cooperate with the committee but let's
see if he does
quick note i don't want to spend a ton
of time on this but donald trump has
decided to cancel the event that he had
planned for tomorrow trump was going to
do a press conference at mar-a-lago his
florida resort tomorrow january 6 2022
the one-year anniversary of the trump
riots on january 6 2021.
he has now canceled that maggie haberman
from the new york times says that quote
among other things several advisers
former formal and informal told trump
the press conference was a mistake
and it was becoming clear he wasn't
likely to get the live tv coverage that
he was hoping for so there's actually
two interpretations of trump's decision
to cancel this one is he realized
there's no way to spin what happened
last january 6th in any way in any way
that would be remotely advantageous to
him that's one possibility
trump's ego tends to push in the other
direction which is i can always spin
anything to be good for me
so the other interpretation is trump got
word that the major networks were not
going to be carrying that press
conference live and decided it wasn't
going to get the publicity that he
wanted and that really does anger the
guy so that has been canceled important
donald trump will be appearing at a
rally in the state of arizona not this
saturday but next saturday uh january
15th and he has put out a statement
saying that then
he will offer his thoughts
on what happened on january 6th so he'll
eventually speak about it but rather
than being in front of what was destined
to be a small television audience he
will do it in front of a live audience
on january 15th we'll have more
information about that that may also get
canceled but the january 6 2022 press
conference trump had planned for
tomorrow at mar-a-lago is canceled make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman's show
we're going to take a very quick break
and be right back
all right we have two more of these
quite frankly very sad stories about
covid deaths even though these are what
some people call
justice in some way i still find these
very sad let's start with the first one
a dozen or more of you emailing me this
deputy district attorney who opposed
vaccine mandates
has died from covid at 46 years old
kelly ernby was a republican she ran for
california state assembly in 2020 she
said there's nothing that matters more
than our freedoms right now at a rally
against vaccine mandates last month
she is now dead
this was the orange county deputy
district attorney kelly ernby
california republican activist
opposed vaccine mandates of all kinds
her boss district attorney todd spitzer
announced her death on facebook quote
the orange county district attorney's
office is utterly heartbroken by the
sudden and unexpected passing of deputy
district attorney kelly earnby kelly was
an incredibly vibrant passionate
attorney who cared deeply about the work
that we do as prosecutors and deeply
about the community we all fight so hard
to protect
um
ben chapman chair of the greater costa
mesa republicans praised ernby as an
inspiration and confirmed she died from
coveted complications
my heart is broken and i'm in tears
wrote ben i lost a dear friend to covet
ernby ran an unsuccessful campaign for
california state assembly in 2020
in december she spoke against vaccine
mandates at a rally organized by the
right-wing student group
turning post usa now i actually don't
know if that's an error and they meant
turning point usa
um i was not able to find that
definitively
but in any case she
in speaking against all vaccine mandates
said there's nothing that matters more
than our freedoms right now
46 years old and she has died of covid
and it is just another one of these
reminders that listen i'm with
i'm with you
and the science in saying this
disproportionately is hitting older
people
this disproportionately is hitting
unhealthy people obesity is a big risk
factor number of other things
but when you've got a bell curve
distribution
uh or even in this case
what may be a pareto distribution skewed
towards the older and the the um people
with comorbidities
when you have a planet of nearly 8
billion people you're going to get
random
younger
in some cases perfectly healthy people
that are going to die
and if it were me
i don't want to take that chance my my
dad the other day sent me a great
analogy to winter tires
which is you know
sometimes all season tires are perfectly
fine even in winter
sometimes you can go an entire winter
and it doesn't even snow in the
northeast or places where it snows
sometimes it can snow and you've got the
all-season tires
and you slip but you don't crash
but wouldn't you rather still have the
winter tires because there might be a
situation where they really do protect
you and prevent you from getting into an
accident that that's really the
perspective
on the vaccination stuff so 46 year old
ernby has died of covid
and we have another one of these stories
that in some sense is even more bizarre
so this next story i know it's going to
be hard for a lot of people to see
beyond the physical appearance of the
individuals that we're talking about
there are twin anti-vaccine brothers the
bogdanov twins who were actually of
memetic fame they were like crypto meme
figures in in cryptocurrency related
memes
both of these brothers whose physical
appearance is bizarre and we'll talk
about that in a moment they both died of
covet unvaccinated within days of each
other now if you're not familiar with
these individuals these are grichka and
igor bagdanov
they
were known
for a couple of different things to some
they were known for their their uh
placement
they figured prominently in
cryptocurrency related memes to others
they were known as having what appears
to be bizarre plastic surgery
if you look at pictures of these
individuals decades ago they look
completely different
they as far as i know denied having
plastic surgery
as you can see you know they have these
cheekbones
that are so bulbous that according to an
australian newspaper they quote threaten
their own vision
um
extremely controversial and and
strange-looking individuals
they obtained doctorates by
writing what are considered allegedly
meaningless physics papers
they claim to be descendants of nobility
etcetera etcetera they're both dead of
covet they're both that of covet the
daily beast writes their voyage through
the stars ended in a parisian hospital
where both grizhka and igor baghdanov
had been admitted on the same day after
contracting covid grichka the younger
twin died in icu on december 28th igor
followed him on monday both were 72
years old a source close to the brothers
told the french media outlet le monde
that neither had been vaccinated against
the virus
um
it is you know you can read about these
individuals if it's interesting to you
but it is another one of these stories
both unvaccinated
both dead of covid and i don't you know
but particularly in this case because of
their appearance and the entire sort of
cult of personality around them
a lot of people are just laughing at
this i i really don't find it funny
it's just sad it's sad and the vaccine
doesn't protect anyone 100 percent but
colin powell
very immunocompromised but had the full
regimen of vaccines died from coveted or
coveted complications it it doesn't
protect everyone
but don't you want a better shot don't
you want a better shot if the suit of
armor is available and you're going to
walk through a forest where arrows are
going to be fired
you might never confront an arrow you
they might go whizzing next to you they
might never actually hit you but
wouldn't you rather the suit of armor if
there are going to be arrows flying
that's my view
and many of you know that already
uh but the bogdanov twins the crypto
meme twins both dead of covid within
days of each other and in the in the
next segment i'm going to tell you about
my confrontation with covet a lot of
people i teased this like 10 days ago
and people have been writing saying
david what what's the deal with that
i wanted to wait to have what was
hopefully the full story i believe i
have it now and i'm going to be talking
about that after the break make sure
you're following me on instagram at
david.pakman you can also follow the
show
on facebook facebook.com
davidpakmanshow we'll take a break we
will be right back
one of the things that kind of pervades
much right wing ideology at least in the
united states
is seemingly
simple obvious ideas
that everybody should clearly hear and
immediately say that makes sense and
adopt
which require no real deep thought of
any kind and
these include things like
uh hey
it's your money after all why should you
be taxed it's your money and you should
get to keep it well this is pretty
simple i don't know it makes sense of
course the real world is far more
complicated
um hey listen uh i mean we've got a
second amendment and so that's it yes
people can have whatever guns and well
but hold on a second let's let's
actually think more deeply about some of
these issues and when it comes to things
like unemployment
welfare benefits
social insurance there's this attitude
from the right that's often based on the
concept of people just got to stop being
lazy and just like go and do stuff go
and do stuff you need more money get a
better job
uh just just just go go go do stuff
don't don't rely on other people don't
be lazy all these different things and
along these lines a very popular meme
that now is being repeated very
uncritically on fox news and in other
right-wing media
is as omicron spreads wildly
and some health agencies
in different states countries etc are
saying employers should be prepared
for
up to 25 percent of their workforce at
any given time to be out because of
either a coveted diagnosis or a covet
exposure that requires some degree of
isolation
they are saying just just go to work go
to work and we have the epitome of
hypocrisy here from fox news is brian
kilmeade the fox and friends crew
appears to be hosting fox and friends
each alone in studios now we can't tell
whether these are all even fox studios
or summer home studios there are people
on other networks who have set up a room
in their home with a big tv screen
behind them and it looks like they're in
the studio but they're really at home we
don't know
but brian kilmeade while he is
co-hosting fox and friends alone in a
studio rather than on the couch with his
co-hosts for any of a variety of
different reasons is telling other
people
just go to work and live with kovid just
just get out there what are you doing
trying to be at home trying to be out
from work
pretty convenient when you can just get
it get your own studio or whatever it is
that he's doing all right let's take a
look at the video here and i want to
make it clear too
that i met so many teachers and angel
you your sister's teacher and your mom
was teacher uh and i met so many
teachers i went to about 18 cities over
the last uh two months and so many
people say i know fox doesn't like
teachers no no you got it all wrong
foxes in all teachers uh the unions that
are in control that they're forced to
join in order to get a job that's the
issue but guess what has changed you
know what he used to be he used to be us
on the couch he used to be almost every
republican uh political leader almost
everyone
saying go get the kids back in school
and the democrats get in charge and it's
like no no we're gonna we need money to
get schools ready and six feet apart and
then we get plexiglass in order to get
and now all of a sudden things have
changed if you see the new mayor of new
york city if you see lori lightfoot of
chicago if you see what is happening in
los angeles everywhere you go in
massachusetts the moderate governor of
republican governor who has really gone
liberal on so many different causes is
now pushing back all on the same page
saying kids need to be in school and
guess the only people standing in the
way are teachers unions the kids need to
be in school the parents need to be
teaching in school the mayor's saying
get into school the governors are saying
getting to school the president's saying
get to school dr fauci said get to
school they're the only thing stopping
these kids are going to have now
remember all along
everybody
said it would be better for kids to be
in school
there was a point at which it would have
been outrageous to do it and school's
this i mean we're getting to the main
thing even this week some schools are
saying we're gonna do we're gonna go
remote for a week or two weeks and try
to get past this this omicron surge but
let's continue their learning curve
forever curtailed unless something
happens quickly and this should be our
mantra from here on in let's not get
caught up in the daily nuances of what
doctors in and what's out it's called
live with it go to work live with it go
to get on a train get on a bus get on a
plane how do we live with it we can no
longer hide from it that's the 10-day to
five-day rule now listen in the real
world uh there's parents that have to
deal with remote learning until they can
get control of their kids education now
there's some degree to which killmead is
not wrong in that we are literally going
to have to learn to live with it one way
or the other how some people live with
it is going to be different than how
other people live with it the the most
optimistic scenario
is we've got another seven to ten days
maybe of this omicron surge
and then a decline meaning in seven to
ten days we'll be back where we are now
and in another seven to ten days we'll
be to where we were seven to ten days
ago and hopefully six weeks from now or
so
things are looking here the way they
were they are looking in south africa
now that that would be the ideal
trajectory
but then the best case scenario is this
thing becomes endemic
and it will be roughly this severe
for a period of time
and hopefully over time the number of
cases gets down to you know what would
be sort of a steady predictable level
the way flu sort of is although there's
better flu seasons and worse flu seasons
we know that
and it continues to mutate because of
evolutionary pressure that generally
makes these things less severe over time
rather than more in the less severe
direction so there is a degree to which
we have to live with it we are in the
middle of the biggest spike
fox
and friends are each sitting by
themselves in a studio as he is saying
get on a bus go to school go here
teachers go in go even when you have a
lot of kids still
unvaccinated very easy and hypocritical
for him to say that and it's you know
the it was the aoc the thing they were
saying about aoc going to miami which we
talked about rules for thee and not for
me he's telling everybody else get on
public transit and just go to your job
where he is you know we can't tell he
may be working from home or isolated in
a studio
probably gets a a chauffeured ride into
the studio or at least it's available i
don't know if he's taking it you know
we're we're sort of guessing here
this is sort of a rules for the and not
for me sort of thing and just a complete
disconnect from the reality of what's
actually going on in the world and if
businesses have 25
25 of workers out
you don't think that cripples businesses
in a serious and significant long-term
way so it's not just hypocrisy it's
virtue signaling as well and we should
all be really skeptical about accepting
the stuff that these people tell us
all right so here's the deal
my girlfriend got covered we have no
idea how and somehow i didn't get it and
we have no idea how so i've been waiting
to tell this story
because i really wanted to be sure i
didn't get it and i wanted to be able to
tell you the full story with some
definition
um so this this now goes back a period
of time but i'm going to lay it out for
you the the way that uh that that it all
is
um
let's call it we'll i'll just use day
numbers okay day one
she wakes up with a sore throat we say
uh-oh let's see what's going on we both
take rapid tests and are both negative
and uh we just hang out at home for the
remainder of that day by the end of the
day she's feeling fine
wakes up on day two says my symptoms are
gone
uh had a sore throat it's gone i'm
feeling fine on day two
end of day two she says i think i'm
still feeling fine but i just i don't
know i've got i'm just really weirdly
tired i don't know a little bit of a
headache okay
we go to day three wakes up she says my
sore throat is back
i'm feeling worse
uh i've got a headache let's go and
actually get
pcrs
uh go get pcr tests told you know it's
gonna be 24 to 48 hours before you get
the result later on day three she
develops a fever so now we've got sore
throat
um and fever
and a little bit of headache i feel fine
uh we're waiting on the pcr results but
she's got fever
we go to day four day four still has
fever using tylenol to manage it i still
feel fine
now at this point we're assuming this
this real this actually could be covered
maybe the rapid test on day one was just
too early day four we get the pcr back
and it says negative everybody's still
negative now that was taken on day three
what would be considered day three of
symptoms
you know day two the symptoms went away
but
it's probably day three of symptoms pcr
is still negative
day four still has a fever fever starts
climbing 101 102
i still feel fine because she has the
negative pcr
i'm thinking well this is something else
we don't really have to worry we're
sharing a thermometer we're sharing food
we are you know i i
drove her in the car
to get the pcr tests we're
sleeping in the same bed yeah it's okay
day four
uh fever is still there
day four at night
the fever
seems to go away
day five
she wakes up i still feel fine she wakes
up and she says
my fever's gone
i'm less
feeling like i'm sick
my throat is about 50 percent better
maybe it's going away all right fair
enough
but then on day five she develops a
cough and it's it's not a good cough
this is the car it's what would be
called in the industry a productive
cough it's a bad cough
i still feel fine other than at this
point i'm having what i would do some
people call it a phantom
uh
a phantom headache and sore throat
some people would call it a jewish
neuroticism headache and sore throat
some some of you will understand what
that means uh but i don't i don't really
have symptoms but i'm kind of like do i
feel something do i feel something so so
now we're on day five and because
we you know still getting negative covet
tests negative pcr negative negative
negative the sore throat she says could
this be strep could this be flu
fever's gone
sore throat
that productive cough is here so we say
well we we need to get
a flu test and we need to get a strep
test i'm still feeling fine we're not
isolating we're in the car driving to
get the strep and flu etc etc
she gets tested for everything day five
at night
gets a call back and they did another
pcr just to be sure you know they test
for rsv other viruses flu strap etc they
say uh ma'am
you're negative for everything
except kovid you have covet and she says
really i had
you know multiple negative rapids
negative pcr
uh et cetera et cetera no it's
definitely covered and you should be uh
she says do i need do i need to isolate
from my partner my boyfriend we live
together and the doctor says yeah you
you really should
um
so at that point i'm just kind of
thinking
if i didn't get it yet
i'm not gonna get it right but day five
you can still be contagious even though
she's had 24 hours without a fever and
this is where it kind of gets to these
mixed messages we have the new cdc
guidance and the old cdc guidance if
you're without fever for 24 hours and
it's been five days in theory you're all
good but are you really do we know what
about omicron
all this different stuff
so we start isolating and we isolate for
three days
sleep in separate rooms and you know
wear masks in the house when we pass
each other i really don't want to get
this thing and okay i had five days of
exposure day after day after day sharing
food sharing thermometer sharing
but we'll just isolate for the for for
the two three additional days
at that point you know she gets to day
nine
and still has the nagging cough but is
otherwise mostly better
and at that point i say
i think i think i beat it i think with
the three doses
clearly i was exposed i was exposed in
the two days before she was symptom in
theory i was exposed on day minus one
and zero because that's when you're
believed to be most contagious and i was
exposed on days one two and three when
you're believed to be most contagious
and i was exposed on days four and five
during which you're in general believed
to be less con i just didn't get it now
could i have had
could i have had an asymptomatic case
yes one that was both asymptomatic and
was negative on uh rapid and pcr tests
now you might say well did you do
subsequent pcr tests i did
on day seven
we both did additional pcr testing she
was still positive
i was still negative
on day nine
we both did rapid tests she was uh we we
were both negative by that point in time
um so i don't know i don't have an
explanation you know it's
i don't know that we will ever really
get an answer other than maybe it's as
simple as the vaccine worked the vaccine
which when you have three doses even
against omicron believe to be
75 effective against symptomatic disease
i mean this this was not passing
exposure that i had i think is the point
i'm trying to make we were in the car
driving back and forth from testing into
the hospital
or the urgent care whatever uh the
different different places to get pcrs
um
and we were you know in the same room
and sharing food
i was clearly exposed and
apparently i had the
you know the neutralizing antibodies
were activated and i somehow ended up
not not getting sick you know you hear
about people across the hall from
someone in a hotel
isolating one person has covered
it you know nicolas christakis told us
about the story the person across the
hall gets it it can be that contagious
i feel like i dodged a bullet somehow uh
five days of of constant exposure really
seven days if you include the two days
prior to syndrome seven straight days of
full exposure
uh and and i didn't get it unfortunately
because we both work from home it didn't
create any kind of disruption in terms
of work or anything like that but
that's my story and you now know
everything i know and the reason i kept
waiting
to tell the story was in my head i was
like okay what if i tell the story now
about how i didn't get it and then
somehow like she's still contagious on
day 14
and then it incubates for five days and
i end up with it on day 19. you know
these on on the edges of the bell curve
scenarios it's now been long enough it's
been you know three weeks that i'm
feeling pretty good
that if i were to get it now it wouldn't
be from that now where did she get it we
have no idea first of all
we
we basically both have been doing the
exact same stuff we go to the same
places we don't do any indoor dining
we're not going to the movie theater
we're not going to sporting events we're
not doing any of that stuff um we we
didn't we didn't really have any indoor
unmasked contact with anybody other than
a car ride with my brother who also
hadn't done anything had no symptoms had
no positive test before after during
um is it possible that this is so
contagious
that some of those other means could
could potentially give you the virus uh
there was an instance where
when we were outdoor dining she went in
to the restroom with a mask on could
there have been a surface thing there
um
grocery store i mean it's we really have
no idea and presumably not only did i
not get it from her but we were both
exposed to wherever she got it
and i i still didn't get it so i don't
know folks i don't know but it is uh
very very wild times and that's the full
story uh as i understand it right now we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to david p i have talked about my
disdain for kids menus here is someone
who misunderstood my comment and isn't
pleased with me take a listen to this
hey david robert asher from st louis
first time caller yes i want to talk to
you a lot about various
trump-related things in my arguments on
facebook with my friends but you were
doing a
thing about applebee's and you talked
about kids menus just being uh what the
adults eat but in smaller portions
as if that were a bad thing but isn't
that what a kid's menu is supposed to be
yes this so you misunderstood
my point was
i am vehemently against
what has become
the de facto american kids menu you go
to a steakhouse or you go to a burger
bar or you go to a noodle shop or you go
to even some asian or indian restaurants
and the kids menu is the same thing it's
grilled cheese
noodles with butter
chicken fingers with fries
no matter where you go i'm against that
what i mean
by the kids menu
is smaller portions of what the adult
seed is
kids should just be having smaller
portions of what the adults eat
you know these these stereotypes oh kids
don't like fish well they don't like it
because a lot of americans don't give
kids fish until they're seven
and by then they've not developed a
taste for it all over the world thailand
japan argentina spain
kids are having shellfish and fish
all the time and that's what it is oh
kids don't like spicy well in india
and pakistan
and thailand and china kids are having
modestly spicy stuff all the time but so
my my point is i like the idea that but
you don't really need a discreet kids
menu because it just be the kids eat
smaller portions of what the adults are
having that's not what is the kids menu
in most places i'm against the grilled
cheese pasta chicken fingers kids menu
please let's understand what i am saying
that's my point all right we have a
great bonus show for you today
the mayo clinic
has fired
700 employees because they are not
vaccinated 700 employees
december job growth
doubled the expected numbers
doubled that sounds like a great economy
well we're going to dig into the numbers
and think about it a little more deeply
and a father and son plead guilty to
trump riot charges it runs in the family
folks
and i'm sort of joking when i say that
but it it really does it really does so
we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
tomorrow's live stream of the trump
press conference is cancelled because
the press conference is canceled we will
have other live streams this week and
next tuesday january 11th 6 p.m eastern
will be doing a very casual
chess tournament
players of all levels are welcome this
is a great community thing last time we
did it i think we had
500 or 600 players it was great some
grand masters international masters
women's feed a masters are going to be
participating in the tournament i hope
that you will participate it'll be
january 11th at 6 00 p.m eastern just
make an account on chess.com and then
i'll have information about how to sign
up it's free i'm selling you nothing
folks it's completely free to play and i
hope that you will all right we'll see
you on the bonus show sign up get a
membership at joinpakman.com
which will give you instant access to
the bonus show
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman